that's the weekend and simicadra leaving
a hotel together in los angeles earlier
this month which caused dating rumors to
swirl and now a source is revealing why
the two may be more than just friends
after acting very couply in las vegas
over the weekend
[Music]
romantic speculation heated up as the
star boy singer celebrated his 32nd
birthday at delilah in sin city saturday
night when he and the dj were seen
locking lips and while the weekend and
semi were previously reported as just
friends a source tells e.t that they
have been seeing each other adding that
the two are having fun together it's
easy since they have known each other
for a long time simi is supportive of
the weekend and they have a natural
flirtation and chemistry
[Music]
rumblings of the coupling first began in
january after simmy and her twin sister
hayes attended the grammy winners dawn
fm album release party then earlier this
month simeon the weeknd left the sunset
tower hotel together following a dinner
date in la
as for the bella hadid of it all
[Music]
[Music]
the model who dated the musician on and
off from 2015 to 2019 and was a longtime
friend of simi's has since unfollowed
simi on instagram after the could be
couple was first linked
[Music]
and while the weekend's dating history
includes bella and selena gomez he was
most recently linked to angelina jolie
after spending time together last year
it was very exciting and following the
release of dawn fm fans immediately
started analyzing this lyric from the
track here we go again thinking it's a
nod to the oscar
[Music]
i told winner that i never fall
in the meantime the take my breath
singer seems to be enjoying his time
with simi
[Music]
you